hey guys how's it going against Essene
welcome back to my kitchen and today we
are celebrating Valentine's Day the only
way that I know how with my heart so
what we're going to be doing today is
we're gonna be making a bleeding-heart
cake now I made one of these I think
last year for Valentine's Day but this
is different because it's going to be an
actual real-life replica of a real human
heart because why not
so I pre-made the cake so that you guys
didn't have to watch me make another box
cake so without further ado Cakes police
oh wow can you believe they just
appeared like this out of thin air so
what we're gonna be doing is we're gonna
be cutting the tops off of these two and
we're gonna be layering these together
so we're gonna have a three-tiered cake
with the bleeding part on top so with
this excess cake from the tops of it I'm
going to mold together to make our heart
so it's basically gonna be like a cake
pop art in theory this is what I'm
thinkin but usually the things that I'm
thinkin never really sort of comes to
fruition properly oh wow look at this so
I'm gonna mix a little bit of this up
with a little bit of butter so that it
will smooth out a little bit easier
because this is this consistency is
thick like my body this is a lot like
this is disgusting if you actually think
about what this is like it is just a ton
of icing
this is getting so fluffy I'm such an
idiot
made a mess already hardly even started
this video I haven't even touched the
cake yet this is a nice little trick
that I saw somebody do once on YouTube
they put icing on this board so that it
sticks I'm gonna cut the tops off of
these can't find my cake leveler so it's
very upsetting that I don't hmm so we're
gonna save this put that into there
cousin really me oh shoot that's not
level I gotta find my cake leveler cuz
this is not the life that I live no you
stay there you monster we can glue that
back together it'll be like it didn't
even happen
you can't even help
[Music]
this is basically the same thing that I
did for the home pod but this time
instead of a home pod and have a
bleeding-heart on top okay so we're
almost done this isn't even anything
that has to do with the actual cake this
is just like to put the heart on it's
definite not my best work
definitely not my worse work we're gonna
be mixing up this lovely little cake
mixture and trying to form it into a
heart I hate everything that's gonna
happen right now
oh I hate it this is gonna be not fun at
all I know I got to go into the hands
but I don't want to this is so
disgusting
and this icing is like an oil bath
it just doesn't oh no I think I'm gonna
put too much icing in do I have
AppleCare on this watch could you hand
me that other cake over there Thanks
yeah here just yeah that's good yeah you
know what I could have done I could have
probably put this in the mixer so I
think we have a nice consistency that I
may be able to form the heart so I know
you're busy like filming and everything
but a lot of that's perfect okay so it's
gonna be kind of like a Lyga looks like
sort of like an egg how's that look just
maybe like you can just have it over
there maybe just I think really just
like flash it like a flash car so
there's a lot of tubes involved in this
heart so I think I might might not be as
photorealistic as I had hoped
yeah I don't know if this is really like
what what a heart looks like it's just a
potato did I make a potato there could
be worse ways to spend your day like you
could be me right now you could be
making this don't worry this will get
better I promise
ah no you want no promises what have I
done this looks stupid
this doesn't look like a heart at all so
things aren't going quite how I expect
it so we need to make kind of like the
arteries and stuff coming out of the
heart somebody makes some fondant
arteries and then I'm hopefully gonna
paint this thing red
I'm not sure I've definitely messed up
my color scheme Oh Stephanie oh come on
man brush slam upon it this point
doesn't even matter
oh this looks like a little calamari
cool oh my god so this is not
biologically accurate by any means but
don't judge me it should be a little bit
more this way but I'm gonna jam it here
just because I think it's gonna fall off
if I put it anywhere else
[Music]
so this is our gonna be using for the
blood these are some country cherries in
a can that's my dog Wow so I'm gonna Jam
one of these inside this little
ventricle here just for a nice added
look so I need to get these nice and
real juiced up like real blood I've seen
Dexter no no no you do not you do not
get to go out like that that is not fair
I'm just gonna dump it on because what
else what's the worst that can happen
I'm not sure this is Oh
[Music]
pretty girls out right now Oh God
[Applause]
[Music]
not really sure what else I can do to
this this point this is not quite what I
had envisioned perhaps maybe better luck
next time well guys this is it I don't
think there's anything more that I can
even do to salvage this because at this
point it's looking like a very very hot
mess thank you guys so much for watching
I hope you guys have a lovely
Valentine's Day if you have any more
suggestions for things that you would
like to see me bake in the future and
that's attempt to bake of course leave
those in the comments below and I look
forward to chatting with you guys there
so in the meantime well I guess I'm just
gonna no I don't know what I'm gonna do
probably go eat this while I watch
Netflix
[Music]
[Applause]